私肇社長
今年へ
う
ラーメンと目の前わー
ああああああ
goo
ブーシェ
al
あっっ去年私お菓子を食べませんという目標を立てて自然が過ごして物理それを達成さ
れました
今岡氏バリバリ食べてますそれなら今すぐ食べますたりばにおかずは食べるんですけど
も
去年ハッハー志端に来て去年1年間おかしい禁止普通だと無理なんですよ僕みたいな
人間はお母さん禁止なんてもう僕の
実は終わったようなもんだったんですけどもどうやってそれを達成したかというと
ラーメンの存在がすごいデカかったです僕結構夜遅くまでおける生活が続いていて
夜中までやっているお店っていうのはたいていラーメン屋さんか柔道しかないんですよ
僕中にお菓子を我慢してて多分心の支えになったのはほぼ
ラーメンでした深夜に行く友達とクーラーレンガ
最高にうまかったもうかけがえのない時間だったので僕にとってはもう男の中の男です
よ
何がわかんないんですけどとりあえずあのお菓子を食べれないとこフラストレーション
を吐き出してたから多分ラーメンでしたコッテコテの池いつも言ってるラーメン屋さん
か今戦やってラーメン屋さんなんですけども
スノー味スープを全部飲み干すとまくり犬ってこういう券がもらえます
バックリー証明証っていうこれあれどトッピングできたりラーメン1杯プレゼントとか
22名
やると丼がもらえたりするんですけども僕去年の1年でどれだけラーメンのスープ
飲み干したかっていうとも多分
かなり漸増じゃないレベルですこれ本当なんだいやちょっと待って
126万円です友達の分も合わせて1年間226倍ラーメンのスープを全部飲み干せ
ます
ん
身体に悪いが冒すより体に悪いほんとねもうなんかラーメン食べなんですけど僕今年
このまま私も解禁してラーメンを食って
で生活していると多分本当にすぐ死にますとね社長になるのは時間の問題だと思うので
今年は
がー名を禁止させていただきます部活禁止にしたことに言って僕の体に変化があります
でおかしい食べたらお腹が膨れてご飯が食べれなかったんですけども今岡せ食べても
ご飯はちゃんと食べれば普通におかしく例えばご飯めっちゃ食べててお札食べてもご飯
がちゃんと食べれるように今なってるのでそこでラーメンのスープを飲み干すんじゃ
なくてもっとちゃんと他のものを食べれば健康にはまだなるんじゃないかと思いまして
今年はラーメンを聞いせさせていただきます
この会社入ってると店員さんにもさすがに覚えられて普通の客様免許とありがとう
ございました
いくんですけども僕が帰るときは用いさんいつもありがとうございますって送ってくる
んですよ
ua
ゴールでやーっていう中山眼科
本当に去年はまずでお世話になりました政府が本当にもう
afra の沼ですよたがやっぱりね飲み干すと剣が折れるって聞いちゃった僕は
やっぱ男なんで全部飲みたくなるんですよ
もったいないじゃないですか
体には悪いけどファーその結果これなんですけど戻しは
ラーメン食べませんラーメン屋さんであった視聴者の方も多いと思います今年はもう
会うことはないと思う
そして今西安の店員さん去年1年間お世話になりました
[音楽]
ちゃまよ動画好きです某米ラスだからねこんなもんラッドでこれを食べてから今年は
もう
ラーメンを食べません今言ったことある人たぶんこの膜池数のすごさは釣っていると
思います
マジで通ってましたがみなさん去年おかしいほどよく飛び鉄でのしっかりご飯食べるべ
その食べるご飯の内容も
ラーメン以外のものを食べるという形で頑張ってこと
いますこの縛りプレイ毎年続きそうだ b でもそれで健康になれるなら僕は我慢し
ます
ん
そして彼は
ラーメンに手を伸ばした
すべてのねー
すべてのスープに感謝し
彼は
ラーメンで別れを告げたのであったっ
yeah
実は今年に入って結構ラーメン食べてお菓子も食べ続けて
ここ2週間で2キロ太ったぜ